hi i'm carter morgan and today i'm going
to share how google cloud app sheet can
help empower citizen developers
to build their own no code applications
let's get started
have you spent countless hours sifting
through an endless list of
out-of-the-box solutions frustrated that
nothing is quite what you'd hoped it
would be
do you ever think to yourself i know
what i need to be successful
i wish i could just build it myself if
so
no need to look any further no code
solutions like google cloud app sheet is
democratizing technology
allowing everyone everywhere including
you to become a citizen developer that
creates custom applications
to meet your unique needs
this means that by leveraging the power
of data non-technical individuals can
build their own applications without
even needing to know how to write a line
of code
by expanding the pool of who can access
app development from 10 million software
engineers
to more than 2 billion people appshoot
is helping increase the number of people
who can provide a quick
solution with the right no code platform
in place
this newfound talent pool of citizen
developers can help their companies
ideate quickly
drive innovation and increase agility in
an ever-changing work environment
but how exactly does app sheet work well
it engages with your data and through
machine learning processes the
information in the data and creates
application that can be used on desktops
for those in the office
or on mobile devices for those in the
field you can think about no code
behaving like a self-driving car
these self-driving platforms allow you
to describe to them where you want to go
and actually will drive you there in
this case your data is the description
and certain data points like dates or
email addresses
influence how your application looks
feels and behaves
there are three key areas of no code
development that set appsheet apart in
the no code space
governance ai ml capabilities and
automation
for now we're going to provide a quick
walkthrough that showcases how google ai
and ml
help you get started with app sheet in
just a few clicks let's get started
first we're going to authorize your data
source on the app sheet homepage click
the start for free button
you'll be taken to a screen that states
start with your data
select your cloud-based data source in
this case we'll be using our google
drive
and authorize your account to work with
app sheet
your data will not be moved it will
remain with your preferred data source
once you've authorized your data source
you will be taken to your account page
for a quick start click make a new app
and select start with your own data
next provide a name for your application
and select the type of application you
want to build
for this app let's build a field service
inspection application
click select data and select from the
list of authorized data sources
select the appropriate file for your
application and then let google's
machine learning analyze your data and
make smart suggestions based on the type
of data in your source
in this survey app appsheet made
recommendations for views of maps
and image gallery in forms based on your
data
from here you can customize how your
application looks and behaves
add automation and decide who you'd like
to share your application with
the emulator on the right provides
real-time updates and different screen
types to the changes you're making so
you can iterate on your application
quickly
from the complex solutions to simple
forms the possibilities are endless for
what can be accomplished with a no code
platform like appshoot
ready to start building a custom line of
business solutions that will empower
your team
get started today by clicking the link
in the description below
happy app building
[Music]
you